[Musica]
wow
ma quanto sono belli questi funghi
chissà se sono anche buoni mi rimangerei
tutti una volta un cagnolino molto
carino con tutti come berlino aveva
sorpreso dire berlino con le banche
sempre mangiare e carini mani non si sa
perché
vitale mio caro mario supermario ma che
cosa ci fai qua dentro
devo raccogliere tutti i funghetti e le
vorrei dire o no e ora che faccio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che cosa ci fai qui i tablet ei
bene
[Musica]
ma come ti sei svestita perché sono
vestito dall'idraulico perché perché
siamo in super mario siamo più
videogioco di superare ma io perdo una
sorta di varco spazio temporale dentro
al mentendo suite
abbiamo provato a raccogliere tutte le
monete dice che può funzionare secondo
avessi io mi fermerò mangiare qualche
funghi atto vero
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no
[Musica]
mario si ma ti sei accorto che non c'è
nessun tubo per venire qua
effettivamente è solo una stanza piena
di monete come faremo a passare al
prossimo livello forse dobbiamo appunto
raccogliere tutte quante le monete
[Musica]
no
si no
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
la nostra camera che bel salto è i
nostri vestiti mi permette che bello
siamo ritornati noi stessi ma è questo
ma cosa sono o no hai rubato un pezzo
del videogioco come ho fatto io numero
sono neanche reso conto se qualcosa qua
dentro
non lo so proprio ma rho pero 18k non si
apre prova ad aprirlo piano che cos'è
sento doti di cibo ok allora facciamo
che contiamo fino a 3
qualsiasi cosa si sia dentro
controlliamo va bene sono d'accordo con
noi siamo pronti albiate al mio testo
un'ora o due
e stasera risotto ai funghi
[Musica]